c'est un bon soir alors vous êtes un
fils de mais votre père ne s'appelle pas
à l'idée depardieu ou dutronc votre père
s'appelait zemmour
edgar zemmour et il était l'un des trois
frères zemour alors la fin des années 60
au début des années 80 les frères et
mourront régnait à paris sur le la
prostitution le jeu les cabarets mais
william zemmour a été abattu en 1975 par
la police edgar votre père a été tué
dans son sommeil en 1983 année qui voit
également l'élimination de gilbert
zemmour voilà alors le 28 février 75
donc un accrochage violent entre les
policiers de l'antigang est là et la
bande de votre père au bar le tlm votre
oncle williams est abattu et votre père
décide de vous mettre à l'abri vous avec
votre mère votre frère votre soeur en
floride à miami voilà vous avez quatre
ans et vous comprenez pas ce qui vous
arrive non non non je sais juste que on
est parti là-bas un que je commençais ma
vie aux états unis j'ai été à l'école
lama toute ma vie et j'étais un peu
à l'écart de tout ça je ne savais pas ce
qui se passait je savais juste que ont
bougé beaucoup et que et que c'était
souvent un peu tendu bah oui c'est tendu
parce que votre père n'est jamais là
évidemment il n'arrête pas de faire des
allers retours entre paris et miami pour
ses affaires votre mère se réfugie dans
l'alcool et vous dit j'ai toujours connu
ma mère ivre je l'aimé comme ça oui
c'est vrai que ma mère je les ai
toujours reconnues comme ça et je pense
comme n'importe quel enfant j'ai gelé
mais peu importe c'est votre mère voilà
ouais alors vos parents ils se bagarrent
quand même c'est de baston quoi quand
votre père est là c'est violent c'est
pas parce que mon père et l'unc que
c'est violent c'est juste que je pense
que quand
quand en pratique ce qu'ils pratiquaient
je pense que c'est c'est difficile de
retenir un peu sa colère quand on rentre
chez soi et qu'on voit que sa femme ait
été vrai que les enfants font un peu
n'importe quoi
je pense que c'est c'est pas très
agréable et voilà c'est ça parfois ça ça
se passait mal quoi alors pour oublier
les pleurs les cris les coups vous vous
réfugiez dans la musique et vous
découvrez supertramp quincy dc led zep
de nac les créateurs de my sharona ou
voilà c'est votre votre jardin secret
quoi c'est celle là dedans que nous
essayer d'oublier le reste en fait
souvent quand ça se passait mal je
m'enferme dans ma chambre et où je
mettais la musique à bloc pour rien
entendre où j'essayais d'écrire votre
père c'est votre idole à ce moment là
c'est à dire que quand vous balader avec
lui tout le monde l'aiment tout le monde
le respect qui fait marrer les gens quoi
c'est un personnage très truculent en
fait garder mon nom ouais je pense
qu'encore une fois - moi j'ai pas le
même regard sur mon père que les gens
qui ont pu avoir
parce que c'était mon père comme
n'importe quel enfant encore une fois je
l'aimais tel qu'il est tel qu'il était
et je sais oui c'était un peu mon idole
et le jeu
je pensais que je pensais que les gens
l'aimaient beaucoup les gens l'écoutent
et les gens les gens l'adoré
l'entouré et puis c'était mon père je
ferai alors ça devient invivable tôt
pour vous pour votre frère et pour votre
soeur à la maison vos parents se
séparent votre mère est expédiée à paris
où elle est rejetée par là par le clan
en arrivant ma mère de toute façon n'a
jamais pris parti de de la famille elle
dit c'est ce qu'elle pensait et elle se
reconnaît pas et c'était pas un trop la
façon dont il faisait les choses
en plus de ça elle avait un problème
avec l'alcool et je pense que la famille
n'acceptait pas du tout souffert
en tous les cas après la séparation de
vos parents le calme revient la maison
votre père vit avec une autre femme il
recommence une autre vie et est à ce
moment là il ya des histoires
incroyables
c'est à dire par exemple un jour vous
suivait des cours de taekwondo et et le
prof de notre coup de règle sur les
mains et qu'est ce qui fait votre père
il est venu et il est rentré à
l'intérieur dit de joe hill a appelé le
prof et il a amené dans le bureau et il
lui a montré la fin il lui a dit que si
jamais me repêcher qu'elle allait mourir
est donc j'ai raté le taekwondo et
onctueux et tomba k12 le mec j'ai dit tu
es gentil avec mon fils y passe en place
il ya aussi une autre histoire qui est
extraordinaire c'est un jour il y avait
un restaurant que votre père voulait
fermer parce qu'il marchait pas et vous
allumer un feu à côté du restaurant et
qu'est-ce qui se passe
je suis rentré à l'intérieur pour dire à
mon père que j'avais allumé un feu qui
me fait un peu dépassé ouais il me dit
qu'on allait rentrer à la maison et donc
en train la maison et le restaurant a
brûlé mais en fait ça l'arrangé parce
que ça marchait pas très bien ce
restaurant est ce que la presse chine
vous connaissiez le métier de votre père
à l'époque non quand il partait c'est
papa est en voyage d'affaires
mais vous savez il est très silencieux
ouais hein vous saviez pas il n'avait
pas de gardes du corps de toute façon
non ouais mais c'est toujours un peu sur
ses gardes quand même ouais il avait des
yeux derrière la tête
il pouvait pas être surpris 1 et puis le
8 avril 1983 ce jour là vous allez au
cinéma nous dormait chez un copain et le
lendemain quand vous rentrez à la maison
donc à miami vous découvrez qu'on a
enlevé la moquette et vous comprenez que
quelque chose de grave s'est passé la
maison est vite vous comprenez tout de
suite que votre père a été abattu ouais
je savais que c'était la fin de quelque
chose du sentier un vide
c'est quelqu'un qui avait une présence
extraordinaire et donc le jour où il a
été tué juste senti que il y avait bien
plus sain il a été assassiné la veille
lors ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
la nuit suivante vous êtes dans cette
maison avec votre frère votre frère à
une carabine dans les mains et il vous
dit pousse toi ne reste pas dans l'angle
de la fenêtre parce qu'il y avait quand
même un risque bien que dans ces
milieux-là se pratique pas mais enfin il
est quand même un risque qu'après le
père les assassins continue avec le
reste de la famille alors après
l'enterrement apparaît donc à tous les
photographes tout ça vous prenez
conscience de ce qu était votre père en
fait au moment de son enterrement un peu
un peu ouais là vous perdez complètement
pied vous dites de 11 à 14 ans tout
s'est éteint dans ma tête je ne parlais
plus je n'existais plus c'était le noir
total tirent là vous avez une un moment
ça bascule quoi mais c'est à dire
qu'après l'assassinât de mon père j'ai
été rapatrié à paris où les gens se se
disputer un peu pour des histoires
légaux par rapport à aux biens et à
l'argent je suis resté j'habitais avec
mon oncle gilbert et trois mois plus
tard il s'est fait assassiner
ouais donc j'ai commencé à prendre un
peu une espèce d'habitude de sentir que
les gens allaient disparaître assez
rapidement et que tout ce que je pouvais
penser avoir entre les mains en fait
jamais j'avais pas quoi ouais donc à
saison vous retourner aux états unis en
fait
et là vous commencez à vous défoncer à
prendre de la drogue à faire des
cambriolages c'est à dire vous vous
tournez mal vous faites six ans de six
ans de prison au total quoi disons avec
des entrées des sorties wii à partir de
l'âge de 18 ans j'ai fait ma première
pas de nos prisons de toute façon à
partir de l'âge de 18 ans de toute façon
j'ai été j'étais tout seul
ouais je le laissais personne à côté de
moi je laissais percevra entré dans ma
vie je
je veux retourner un peu toute cette
histoire contre moi j'essaie de me punir
pour quelque chose qui m'appartenait pas
du tout de ma première peine de prison
je pense ça a été plutôt un soulagement
puisque autre chose parce que en fait ça
m'a empêché de continuer à me faire du
mal
c'est vrai que la prison soit pas été
facile en l'occurrence quand j'étais en
prison
la première chose que j'ai fait c'est de
recommencer à écrire
ouais il faisait même devenu écrivain
public pour le pour les autres oui ce
qui s'est passé c'est que aux états unis
souvent dans les cellules où on est à
plusieurs dans cette cellule en
l'occurrence on était à peu près à 40
il y a toujours un détenu qui est chargé
de régner sur les autres est en fait
cette personne là un soir ma vie en
train d'écrire venu à regarder ce que
j'étais en train de faire a trouvé ça
bien et m'a demandé si je pouvais écrire
des poèmes pour sa petite amie donc je
lui ai écrit un poème pour sa petite
amie lui envoyer
elle a commencé à venir le voir et lui
donner de l'argent lui apporter de
l'argent et
donc il m'a demandé si je pouvais
continuer à faire mal et on échange un
protégé et donner à manger ainsi de
suite vous dites que vous retournez dans
ces prisons par exemple il faut faire
très attention ne pas dire quand est ce
qu'on va sortir parce que si on va
sortir dans pas longtemps
les mecs t'agresse pour que tu restes
toi avec eux en prison pour tu croupis
savais que mon prison pour pas que tu
t'en ailles ont vaincu l'équipe
ouais en fait n'importe quel détenu qui
rentre dans une prison en floride où
j'étais il n'y a pas assez de place en
fait c'est un les prisons sont un peu
surchargé donc ils n'ont pas la
possibilité de séparer les petites
peines avec les grosses peines donc tu
peux te retrouver dans une prison avec
quelqu'un qui va sortir en 2075
et cette personne n'en a rien à [ __ ]
de toi ni de la loi ni des reines et de
commettre à notre morte ça veut
absolument rien dire pour donc s'ils
savent que vous avez l'opportunité de
sortir ça alors ça leur met un peu la
haine et invite le garder avec eux ça va
systématiquement il ya quand même de la
solidarité c'est pas tous les gens ne
réagissent pas comme ça
il ya très peu de soleil ça nous avait
bien été un c'est pas tout le monde sait
que à la fin de la journée c'est comme
chacun pour soi en prison et les les
gens en prison qui était avec vous savez
que vous étiez le fils de gaz et moi
lorsque j'étais jeune et j'ai toujours
eu mon anonymat
ouais jamais été perçu comme la chine ne
resterait donc vous repartez vraiment à
0 vous vous mettez à la recherche de
votre mère et puis vous découvrez que
qu'elle est morte quoi ouais
la dernière fois que j'avais parlé avec
ma mère c'était quand j'étais en prison
fédérale et je l'avais eue au téléphone
elle était dans un hôpital et c'était la
dernière fois que je lui avais parlé
quand je suis revenu en france
j'ai quand j'ai commencé à faire des
recherches pour essayer de la retrouver
personne ne savait où elle était on
savait qu'elle était partie de l'hôpital
et on n'avait plus revu
donc j'ai commencé à aller à clichy où
elle habitait ouais à marcher dans la
rue faire faire les bars ou peut-être je
pense elle a trouvé les gens se
souvenaient d'elle mais elle avait pas
vu depuis un moment donc j'ai commencé à
faire les rues les bancs les trottoirs
si je voyais une femme par terre qui
vous ressemble et peut-être un peu à ma
mère j'allais vers cette personne mais
je n'ai pas trouvé comme ça en fait j'ai
été à la mairie je leur ai donné son nom
et sa date de naissance et ils m'ont
donné un acte de décès ouais et
et alors ce qui est extraordinaire je
trouve c'est que grâce au rock'n'roll
vous arrivez à briser cette malédiction
c'est à dire que tout ce qui tout votre
énergie vous là vous la mettez dans la
musique vous la mettez dans le rock
vous avez fait un premier album qui
s'appelle heavy duty barbade qui est en
liaison d'ailleurs avec cette nuit vous
étiez avec votre frère en train
d'attendre dans cette dans cette chambre
le lendemain le 9 avril au lendemain de
la mort de votre père cc liée à ça ça
chauffe chez criminels riz corde il ya
un morceau qui est le single qui
s'appelle aux maï maï par them
[Musique]
alors vous vous avez voulu mettre quoi
dans cet album toute cette histoire tous
les je savais que temps que cet album
serait pas écrit je pourrai jamais
passer à autre chose
donc c'était important pour moi de de
l'enregistrer de l'écrire et des jamais
m'arrêter mais pas c'est autre chose
d'en faire d'autres j'espère d'albums -
le deuxième album est déjà en cours ils
savent bien il tombe bien j'ai écouté
tout l'album c'est très très bien ça va
mieux là je pense que je n'oublierai
jamais mais
je vivrai pas dedans non plus le reste
de ma vie quoi je pense que mon passé
fait partie de mon histoire je pense que
ma vie fait partie de ma musique que ma
musique fait partie de ma vie et que
j'ai rien à cacher quoi et depuis
longtemps parce qu'on a parlé de ta vie
de ta survie et la musique c'est là elle
était omniprésente quand même notre avis
ouais ouais ouais
d'ailleurs on a on en a pas parlé mais
quand j'ai monté un groupe quand j'étais
en prison avec d'autres détenus il y
avait une
voilà c'est ça c'est ça a littéralement
c'était ça dans la salle de musculation
il y avait une salle de répétition où il
y avait des des instruments de musique
et personnes l'avaient utilisé depuis
très très longtemps et quand je suis
arrivé en prison j'ai été pour commencer
à faire un peu de muscu parce que
c'était quand même important mais j'ai
vu cette cette salle de répétition et
j'ai demandé si on pouvait l'utiliser
ils m'ont dit que si j'arrivais à
trouver d'autres musiciens dans le la
prison jeu j'aurai le droit de
l'utiliser deux fois par semaine donc
j'ai trouvé un bassiste un batteur et un
guitariste pour ceux qui voulaient qui
restent avant toi les cordes de guitare
ça va faire des tatouages
voilà c'est ça et d'ailleurs je me suis
vu faire un tatouage avec une corde de
guitare pendant que j'étais en prison
c'est vrai il était fier de ton père
ouais je suis fier de lui s'il ya une
chose qui m'a appris c'est que si tu
fais quelque chose fait la faune ne lui
ont pas du tout avec les frères zemour
ils étaient 3 donc ils sont rêver de
sétif en algérie en 55 et ils sont
devenu en 20 ans lesquels ils doublaient
du cycle 1 on les appelle et du week-end
à l'époque
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux